[音楽]
ua 金ちゃん初めてそうです誰か
助けてください無料カードに
ハマってしまいました
[音楽]
いやほんとちょうどべきでやはり不要カードにはまってしまいました大変なんですや
あのー
嘘だけれど飾ってみてくださいこれ気づいたら秒カードをたくさん買ってました0で
で動画学んだよどうかハマってしまったかというと何がありまして
流れが破断あのまずねあのみんなでみんなであのう
部分って言うよ晴れ犬食いの声で打っててちゃんとティッティスタートできるって言っ
てこれ買ったらすぐ
ポケモンカードあのまで町村もとコートの端書士は小山市と知りでくれるだ
ジャズ普通に話せますボケも方にドハマりしてしまいました
果汁社長ですまあ縦横て説明すると全然ねあんま粒じゃなかったんですよ全然やる気が
なかったらに何かたまたまみんなであのー
このスターターデッキっていうか言ってましてこういうのがね今ね微を特区さんと水
しかないんですけどもね色んなタイプのできる売られててそれでみんな買ってやってに
映って買ったら
君ストーンを浄化悪化でびっくりしましたポケモンカードを白い
てくらあのはまったじゃないましてまあ何が本当すごかったって言うとなんか試しに
やってみようと思ってやったら
開始5分でルールをマスターしてしまい複雑なとこは全然わからないんですけど基本的
なルールはなんか5分で覚えてるってやったことなかったのに誰
これ大するんじゃねっと負けないぶーって門永田町前って言ったらなんかすごいハマっ
て気づいたら柄がまだでしてしまう
ああああああ
踏まえてくらい面白いんですよ本当に助けてください
では助けないでいいんですけどリズナが最近急にポケカフーガきちゃってすごい大変な
ことになっております始めシャツをでございますてがすごいねオランダってね銀行
なんかしてるこれなんとデッキ以降
衝撃の500円ですよ可能とりあくりできるんだったらねやっちゃいろんな方が買うよ
ねー
受けて買ったら本当に面白くて最近みんなんで売買カモンカードやっておりま
アッシャー面白い本とねあのこれいくだけでもすぐ楽しめて闇の道をたどっております
あの皆さん知ってると思うんですけど僕
ハマりすぎるとそれしかになんなくなるんですよ優良カードの予想だったし活動等も
ヤバい時もう他の店もしなくなるしてぼく何か熱中しちゃってそれでしか見えなくなる
んでちょっとやばいばその見てこれあの
ダメ間ダメージカウンターペ
この例えばピカチュウがアイアンてってこう入りして10食らうと10ダメージ入るん
ですよ
とりあえずちょっとこんなハマりすぎたっていうかもうちなみにあのアイゼンねはい俺
のにデッキ使っているかと言うとハゲタイプのデッキ使っていますメタグロスダグド量
はで強いんですよ
ちょっととっ子これだけでも十分楽しかったんですけどもやっぱりで言って点火した
ってなっちゃったっていうことであの
今言ってゼラーの映画のバックラベルですよパック今日ちょっとに box 買ったね
これだけで定住を上げる
ただ西へと連でぽ入門カード何がいいかっていうとねみんなでもわかるじゃん知ってる
ポケモン出るとあのまあサーブでもないんですよそうって思ったらだけちょっと見せて
いこうと思います見て皆パチですよ
はつりするマユルド懐かしい
4つんベアラアイアントップ
ね少しか治り
うんやっぱホワイト切れば方へと着ればそんな高くないした分4枚ですよね
8枚で300円なんかに光ってるカードすごい方をしてるのがあるんだよね
お化けから5 gx でか床の音なんか gx 作る強いんだよね2枚やってくれ
2枚800円 dondoko 4
まあ待って俺やばいなんかヤバいマークから後に呪われてるのかもしれないまた
マグカルゴですねが光り方8月なんだけどこれええ待ってこれは the 同じじゃ
ねえ
ふざけに及ばず7こっちや和装を取った見解です
殴るかでも使わいいからね小平とりあえずねゼロってゼロライナー
止め馬て屋根光る川面でなくなっちゃったせめていながら今00は出たんだしたいんだ
よね
4バッハ
いややばいかわかんない薄い組めたイランとのカップ in だよ全部
いやこれ絶対あうぅううああ
ビリジオン ex うわあああっやべっ夏目て言いたいわけじゃないんだけどできれば
か欲しいよねっていう話
て03かペルーかブルー
た皆さんこれはさせて2万5位でしょ神様各部ローン
され系ですか白鵬はホワイト切れば振っちゃった俺やばい
上がって見た見た見たことブルー待ってかぶり次
ホワイトキュレム塗膜狩る事株ブルーをかぶってなければお米だで盾だ
サンダーマウンテンこれで仕方なかったん
の思うん
ちゃんと満点たかったしまう400円です
絶対安いも引いたら絶対火ドラマやすいお値段ティ e 300えんさんねやっぱりね
キードラ300円どうなんだよ
うんわー
ゲノセクト gx 学研カードを混ぜ買って牛てくる高い日がずれる裸を好きでもしれ
へんなくてヒヤってよじゃ件
えっ音ですでこれをこれを
2あディアルガディアルガてやるかいやディアルガは伝説のポケモンなんで
佐々木2台や本の表紙に向かってますからそれにまあこれでしょ
3ねえです
待ってこんな頭揉んだらヤバいんでる頭がこんな頭ますボケも母さんってこんなことは
あろうかと思いと分かっておりますこっちで俺患うらを当てて神になり電気デッキを
作って世界寄せ上げて来ない
これで0ラーが出なかったらショップで凹みますがポケモンカードはやります
かぷブルマって何かさっきと同じような流れたんだけど
レザーってな迫れでだ手が出るアツロウチークでこれねあのを見せてみたいですよ声援
ぐらいでしょ
1,480そんな買い性欲は14年8 n だったーー
めっちゃかっこいいんだけどカーンこ飯
もし味
[音楽]
8計8世はいですかいますからね
俺もう満足もう0よ調べたんだけどゼロなよりレアなカードが入ってるんだよ
めっちゃたらよ
[音楽]
ほこれだが1基がするため何か黄色に光ってるんだよカウンターゲインという
ヒールに光ってますこの艦これやばいんじゃないと思うって
3,480円3,480
これよこれでウソ出そう
308山カッターであったさっきの400は兄ちゃんコクーンでメタ揉めたものですよ
味えマジで
[音楽]
ラグから無事 x
ふふっだ
car
dea
ana あああっ
まずアプリもカードおもしろくてすとハマりすぎのでまずで怖いんで男とにみんなで
エンジョイしていければいいなと思っておりますしてがゴリラ店で始められるのますで
やばいよねーな
登竜門カードはほどよく楽しません
あっ傷に50ダメージ